if you remember we went to Fred's
bachelor party and at the bachelor party
Fred drank 15 tequila's maybe 16 at this
point followed by a beer each time
followed by a beard each time within two
hours I really you know even the 16
tequila's would be enough but 16 beers
Fred passed out flat on his face we
thought he was dead so we told Gary
quickly call the EMS because we had to
get Fred to the hospital right he was
dead he was bleeding from all over so
did you ever get down and actually touch
Fred when he was in this condition I
don't want to touch no I've learned that
you don't touch someone when they're in
that condition in other words you never
went near Fred absolutely not every
article I ever read don't touch the body
it didn't say don't touch the body you
have if you see somebody drop you have
to determine whether they're alive no I
should oh I did I was down by him did I
physically grab his head no I was did
you take his palm
no his Breno I don't know how to take
his pulse and I don't know how to check
his breathing anyway so here yeah just
keep in mind that I walked into the room
and somebody just said call 9-1-1 I take
Fritz pulse I couldn't take French pulse
now let alone there I didn't know what
was going on somebody said just call
9-1-1 right
you wouldn't know how to check to see if
somebody's still beating no I wouldn't I
do not get it I am NOT in the medical
profession you hold your glasses to his
mouth please I'm not gonna put my
glasses to his mouth you put your
glasses to his mouth he saw Fred
bleeding and he ran believe me I saw
what was going on in fact I was the one
who first pronounced Fred dead I said
Fred's dead that's it that's it so
here's Gary who quickly called first he
called his machine to check for messages
and they quickly called EMS I just want
to hear his be interested I have not
heard this yet bye
between second and what's wrong there
okay this place is called score scores
at the ores yeah
first floor yes hold off the EMS don't
hang up the phone okay you're still you
haven't even talked to you mesh yet I
could hear her giggling at your teeth
you hear her chuckling yes yes no you
can you hear the music in the background
but what's interesting to me is that
Gary instead of telling them what's
wrong first game asked you Robin would
you crazy
I didn't hear a question oh hey come on
he's handling himself pretty well
breathing awake how could you see he was
away I didn't know I walked into the
room
Fred was down I didn't see anything
someone said call 9-1-1 quick nobody had
time yeah but I mean you think I was
unconscious I did not see that you see
him laying on the floor waited I mean I
throw on the floor you were the wrong
guy to send the wrong guy no yeah I
think so
well gee well we'll take our time if
he's awake well why does he walk over
logical I think he's male you know I
didn't say that she was away the whole
point was he was unconscious everybody
knows now I couldn't see that
[Applause]
NASA's head open or something you know
what it is you got to sound like
something's real bad - well this is
really bad Fred's unconscious Gary
please Gary backpedals hey limit Howard
Howard there were people that were
saying oh don't call 9-1-1 yeah that was
Ralph no I was saying I said should we
call to be called now we don't need to
call our maybe we better call no it was
Ralph he doesn't know you never looked
over to see what condition fred was in
no I did he knew what condition he was
in he gets confused by the questions how
could I tell he was unconscious boy he
wasn't moving but I don't know maybe he
could hear me you gotta say everything
is bad because did she just say is he
bleeding and you said you can't tell me
I could not tell you was a pool of blood
around it was 40 I didn't see a pool of
blood oh my god no wonder they took so
long they would have been there faster
they were there very quickly they were
there in two seconds what's that there
would have been there one second if you
told them they were bleeding it's a
miracle they showed up god bless EMS
wait Gary was making the probably the
woman orders today what's with you guys
he's not bleeding he's conscious how
could a guy split his head open and not
be bleeding only and Gary's world you
guys are the big news conscious with no
blood I believe he's eating a burger
with some kitchen Howard I see sliced
onions is there anything if you could
jump by here and just take a look for
yourself
is there anything in the world that you
and Robin can't do better is there
anything oh this I definitely could have
done better
no I didn't because I was assisting Fred
doing what you were standing on the side
Do You Know Who I am Howard Stern that's
right
who are you what is your job through
what is it Bob a buoys job typical all
right we have emergencies you ought to
take care of them but you got to handle
yourself in a more brilliant way I can't
imagine that you see a bunch of people
crowded around one of your friends and
you don't break through to see what's
going on he knew I saw Baba Booey he
knew what was going on
versus a panic and somebody said no no
he's telling me he stood there while
there was a debate every saw Fred's body
everyone was laying unconscious with a
pool and Gary choked on the phone we
explained he would happen and thanks on
the EMS worker AMS worker was conscious
shut up can you believe this guy
am I here and he saw everything Gary saw
everything he doesn't listen to the same
thing when I tell him back back in the
office to do something what does he not
believe his own eyes no Robin the entire
debate saw don't trust my own vision you
can shut up because you weren't there
and you don't know any here's the Gary
puppet where is Gary puppet I want to
talk to him
that's who I'm interested in speaking to
my right-hand man is a panicking dope if
you think this is bad you should have
heard what my uncle did back in Dallas
in 1963 what was that
hello Dallas mr. JFK's in the car I
think he's Kasich conscious and his wife
doesn't seem to be too upset is that
right
had a real big bead on the situation
admit you panicked
[Music]
I believe he is why would you believe he
was you should put the phone in front of
Fred's unconscious mouth it's amazing
how you get everything wrong and this is
I tell you that this is not the first
time I'm telling you now I have proof
that it's just how he handles my
business activities Gary when he was
drunk he was out I said the guy is you
always have to act like you know when
you don't wait a second why would I
always give an answer when you don't
know this is your problem when you don't
know something you say I don't know you
didn't know you said I don't know if
he's in a pool of blood I don't know if
he's bleeding I don't know
he was self-conscious about his teeth in
front of all the girls there's a den in
my headphones now what did you have to
say I said you were probably
self-conscious about your teeth in front
of all the girls girls around the phone
okay if I made the pin Gary I would just
like to say one thing he didn't lie
sometimes he just says things that later
turned out to be untrue your piece of
wood
why does he believe if he doesn't know I
believe that he is not bleeding then why
are you calling he was in the room he
knew what was going on panic panic all
right that's it stupidity is better to
plead
I suppose them panic I don't know
congratulations are turning a minute and
a half tape into a half hour bit oh wow
a genius all right thank you